if you happen to drive by the las vegas
convention center yesterday you probably
heard the familiar sound of screeching
tires sema back here in the valley today
is day two of the big show and bianca
hallman gets to hang out there again at
the las vegas convention center she's
got the latest in automotive technology
and uh bianca you're so close i was
hoping you might just be able to you
know drive over here and show us what
you got
oh yeah i wish but this place is on
lockdown because there are a lot of
really really nice vehicles and some
celebrity vehicles here at sema this
year i'm joined here by max magnolas
with sema so tell us about this this
nice sleek looking black vehicle right
behind us so this is a vehicle that the
sima garage did in partnership with ford
and many of our sema manufacturers it's
keith urban's 1969
mustang
we got the car and actually his wife
nicole bought it for him and the car was
actually never done right so it was it
was not restored correctly we took on
the project we heard about it through
our friend jay leno
we took on the car brought it to the
sema garage went completely through the
car we did what we call a resto mod
where we kept the original look of the
car but we added modern features to it
oh yeah this car looks so good i mean it
gets almost giving me a little bit of
night rider vibe you know it's nice and
sleek all blacked out and then we got
this other one which looks older but
this is special tell us about this uh
pickup truck here yeah so this is where
kind of two industries collide right
this is a 1979 f-100 ford pickup but
it's been remodeled with uh all electric
motors so it's
what we're calling now
again a restomod but a lot of vehicles
now are being refitted with electric
motors yeah that's the trend electric
vehicles people are looking forward to
that and i understand you know electric
vehicles that's the wave of the future
but also investing in our youth and
getting them involved in the automotive
industry you all are doing a lot as an
organization sema to get the young folks
involved yeah absolutely we have a few
different programs we have launch pad
which is a program where uh if you're a
brand new startup company you can come
to the show here it's a little bit like
shark tank where you can bring your
products and we vote on them and decide
who's got the best new product and
that's for new entrepreneurs and then we
also have a program called young guns
which is a program where
young builders who want to customize
vehicles get to compete in a class just
for the young guns and the best vehicle
there wins as well pretty cool stuff and
not so encouraging because we need the
we need the next generation involved
making these decisions coming up with
those cool ideas because it can all be
done we were just talking about 3d
printing and if you can see it in your
mind it can become a reality so all
great things happening here at sema and
coming up in the next half hour i know
you want to see me in a vehicle again
yesterday we were on our side leaning in
the truck and when the bronco remember
yes
we may be doing some special effects
we remember safely bianca that you were
leaning at a 30 degree angle
she was trapped in holding on for dear
life right